yves d'amécourt bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin pour
notamment échanger sur la ruralité avec
10 benarroch qui va arriver d'un moment
à l'autre a pour nous rejoindre avant de
parler ruralité peut-être un mot sur la
campagne présidentielle et cette course
parrainage qui continue valérie pécresse
anne hidalgo emmanuel macron qui on le
savait on dépasser le seuil des 500
parrainages à mais aussi nathalie
arthaud hier la candidate de lutte
ouvrière et cela finalement en dépit
d'un faible poids politique alors que
d'autres parties plus représentatifs
sont à la peine yves d'amécourt votre
réaction sur sur ces chiffres ces
derniers chiffres concernant les
parrainages d'à côté ça monte
tranquillement
les candidats qui avaient pris leur
décision d'être candidat il ya cinq ans
déjà on travaillait depuis cinq ans donc
c'est logique qu'ils arrivent plus tôt à
l'objectif de 500 parrainages on avait
hier avec nous jean lassalle qui
s'approche des 500 parrainages crois
qu'il est à 471 parrainage et donc il
arpente la france depuis cinq ans donc
qu'il a il a pris et des assurances et
un certain nombre de promesses de
parrainages voilà donc tout ça je suis
pas très inquiet je pense que les
candidats qui aujourd'hui sont bien
placés dans les sondages auront leur
parrainage
d'ailleurs le le président des maires de
france ce david lisnard dit hier qu'il
était prêt à parrainer un candidat de
gauche pour montrer que l'enjeu du
parrainage c'était pas un enjeu de
conviction mais un enjeu de démocratie
de conviction justement on a vu il ya
des recours dans le nôtre prod notre
reportage il ya quelques instants les
difficultés des petits maires à faire un
choix justement adrien denis le maire de
noaillan village a été exclue de votre
mouvement vous le connaissez le
mouvement de la ruralité après 100
parrainages justement faveur du candidat
eric zemmour reconquête car il a été
jugé incompatible avec le mouvement
regarder ce que dit votre président
national et 10 puijalon il faut être
clair dans la vie avoir une ligne de
conduite il y a un code d'honneur le
respect du travail en commun un soutien
à zemmour est incompatible avec notre
mouvement
alors on l'a vu la difficulté de 7,6
mère justement qui ont une pression le
voit aussi dans votre partie pas de
soutien à eric zemmour pourtant lui à
soutenir vos trente propositions hier et
yves d'amécourt alors cette information
a été démentie en fait si vous voulez
elle a été démentie d'ailleurs en direct
hier par eddie puyjalon devant eric
zemmour la problématique particulière de
adrien de nice et que c'était notre
candidat aux prochaines élections
législatives
il était notre responsable régional pour
les pays de la loire et il a décidé
d'être candidat pour reconquête donc on
peu bas si vous voulez être dans un
parti être candidat dans un autre c'est
tout
parrainage la question du parrainage n'a
rien à voir avec tout ça nos mères sont
libres de parrainer qui ils souhaitent
et qui ils veulent et donc hier
d'ailleurs un démenti a été envoyé à
ouest france ea et au courrier de
l'ouest pour pour expliquer que cela
cela n'a rien à boire et bien démenti
prise en compte également ce matin donc
sur rt france en tout cas peut-être
cette dernière question sur les
parrainages est ce que c'est c'est bien
le rôle des maires aujourd'hui de ne pas
révéler les candidats à la
présidentielle est ce que le système
fonctionne selon vous
écoutez je crois que ce sujet c'est
l'arlésienne on est face à un monde
politique qui ne prend jamais ses
responsabilités puisque à chaque
élection présidentielle la question se
pose et le lendemain de la question de
l'élection présidentielle on l'oubli
donc quand jacques pélissard était
président des maires de france il avait
fait une proposition que les maires
puissent faire de parrainage un
parrainage de conviction un parrainage
démocratique cette proposition a été
applaudi à l'époque mais elle a été
oubliée ensuite d'autres propositions
sont sur la table comme des parrainages
citoyens avec un certain nombre de
parrainages tout est possible je pense
qu'il faut quand même qu'ils infiltrent
parce que sinon on va se retrouver avec
50 candidats à l'élection présidentielle
ou alors on peut organiser une élection
présidentielle à trois tours avec un
premier tour qui est un tour de
parrainage et puis ensuite les deux
autres tours mais il faudra trouver des
solutions mais il faut pas abandonner la
question le lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle parce que ça c'est d'elle
c'est une lâcheté et revenir cinq ans
après en disant on n'a pas ce système
est injuste alors ils d'amécourt dit
benarroch va nous rejoindre dans
quelques instants pour parler justement
de ruralité hier vous avez fait trente
propositions à des candidats qui se sont
déplacés des candidats finalement
essentiellement de droite c'est plutôt
une thématique de droits atteint
aujourd'hui la ruralité comme on vous
l'expliquait
en fait c'est pas tout à fait vrai
puisque on a trois candidats qui sont
pas venus parce qu'ils pouvaient pas se
rendre à notre invitation
personnellement parmi eux il y avait
fabien roussel le candidat du parti
communiste français qui serait bienvenu
mais souhaitait être représentés or on
avait fixé comme règle qu'on accueillait
que les candidats en chair et en os et
donc ben en fait tous les candidats tous
les candidats qui ont intégré dans leurs
projets politiques l'idéologie d'europe
écologie les verts forcément n'était pas
présente puisque puisque ils sont contre
la chasse ils ne reconnaissent pas les
chasseurs comme des acteurs de
l'écologie ils sont contre la forêt
cultivée ils sont contre l'agriculture
telle que nous la pratiquons en france
et donc forcément on n'a pas beaucoup de
points communs toutefois il y avait
aussi gaspard conique qui étaient là et
qui qui en fait n'a signé qu'une toute
petite partie des points mais venus
débattre avec nous de sa conception à la
fois du monde rural et de l'écologie et
donc nous c'est ce que nous souhaitions
c'est avoir un débat on n'a pas réservé
ses prises de parole aux seuls candidats
qui signait la majorité des points alors
les écologistes qui n'étaient pas là
hier pour signer votre 30 propositions
mais qui sont là ce matin
représenté par guy benarroch qui nous a
rejoint bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce matin
pour revenir sur ce grand oral et pour
parler ruralité
justement la ruralité est ce que cette
question là elle devrait pas être une
priorité pour pour les écologistes
savais tu n'es les contrats revanche que
je viens d'écouter à l'instar de 100
études totalement et si on la
redéfinition du modèle agricole qui
enverra pas
les paysans les agriculteurs à la ruine
ou à la mort et sur l'utilisation de
l'espace rural et sur le fait d'arriver
à entretenir cet espace et à le bâtir
également au niveau de la sécurité et du
traitement
qui en est fait par les urbains
différents bords 12 avoir une réelle
politique rurale bien entendu c'est
absolument pas et des bas a confisqué
par personne il par la droite qui par
quelqu'un d'autre en tout cas c'est une
des priorités est ce qui nous concerne
ça en fait partie alors quand on parle
en réalité en tout cas on pense aux
chasseurs un électorat soyez par la
droite on lisait par la droite radicale
est également à l'image de d'eric
zemmour regarder
je refuse et je refuserais que qui que
ce soit vous interdisent la chasse les
vrais écologistes c'est vous et pas les
citadins qui veulent des biches comme
dans bambi alors guy béart auch ont
envie d'entendre les chasseurs les vrais
écologistes pour eric zemmour ce sont
les chasseurs est pourtant un électorat
dans le viseur de votre famille
politique finalement et vous avez ce
rapport à la nature qui est en commun
là encore je viens d'autres des choses
qui sont axées vers des contrevérités
d'abord ce que c'est par exemple on sait
que 70 professeurs des chasseurs sur les
urbains voilà et que 10 % les chasseurs
français vivent dans l'agglomération
parisienne il sait pas non plus qu'à 26%
des ruraux puisse parler des nouveaux
qui sont favorables à la chasse telle
qu'elle est pratiquée
merci pour ça j'ai dû bien c'est à dire
un cas il nous ne sommes pas pour
intégristes de la sias nous sommes juste
pour que la salle soit mieux encadrée de
deux factions et socialement d'avoir
créé une journée sans chasse par se
vendent et deuxièmement en interdisant
certains nombres de chasse n'a pas
beaucoup c'est ce qu'elle a fait les
chasse cruelle et qui sont en général
d'ailleurs totalement dépassés en
l'occurrence essentiellement la chasse à
courre et la vénerie sous terre voilà et
je ne pense pas d'ailleurs et nous ne
pensons pas que les chercheurs ne soient
pas des protecteurs de l'environnement
de swap écologistes en ce qui nous
concerne nous n'avons pas pour vocation
de supprimer la chasse en france juste
de la réguler combiné d'ailleurs de tous
les pays pitoyable afin que soit le
royaume uni l'espagne la hollande ce
sont des pays où travaux la chasse est
pratiquée et où ils existent contre
autrui une journée ça fasse parseval
yves d'amécourt justement c'est cette
régulait réguler régulation bardon de la
chasser ces mesures trop contraignantes
que voulait faire sauter vous
aujourd'hui
je voudrais dire que c'est bien dommage
que yannick jadot n'ai pas répondu à
notre invitation parce qu'il aurait pu
venir expliquer son projet politique
hier nous avons invité tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle à
venir se prononcer devant les présidents
départementaux de du mouvement de la
ruralité et c'est dommage qu'il n'ait
pas saisi cette opportunité
ensuite
notre projet à nous c'est un projet de
convivialité le monde rural c'est un
endroit où on dit encore bon jour où on
dit encore au revoir on respecte les
gens ou comme quelqu'un s'installe dans
un dans un village il est tout de suite
les gens viennent faire connaissance
avec lui ce modèle là cette convivialité
qui existent dans le monde rural elle
n'existe plus dans le monde urbain notre
projet est bien plus large que la simple
chasse et les chasses la chasse à courre
n'est pas une chasse cruelle qu'est ce
qui est cruel est ce que c'est une meute
de chiens qui va mettre un certain ferme
ou est ce que c'est les loups les ours
que veulent réintroduire partout en
europe ecologie les verts qui tue un
troupeau de brebis tout ça n'a aucun
sens bien évidemment la chasse à courre
c'est une tradition ancestrale c'est le
droit de la pratique et est issu de la
révolution française et donc ne pas
connaître la chasse à courre et l'a
qualifiée de chasse cruelles c'est un
non sens et c'est vraiment une
méconnaissance de cette tradition
française imeda roche vous répondez sur
la chasse en vous a vu réagir et puis
après on avancera sur le dossier
vous me dire que vraiment le ccd clichés
que j'entends à la réintroduction des
ours qui c'est qui est cruel et pour
lequel europe écologie et en
l'occurrence leur part les écologistes
mettent leur parle de la partie serait
favorable ça encore une fois c'est une
c'est une image d'épinal on va dire ça
comme ça en ce qui concerne les chasse
cruelle je me permets juste de me
référer par exemple à la compatibilité
qui a souvent été démontré pendant droit
européen ou conseil d'état qui s'est
prononcé à plusieurs reprises sur
l'incompatibilité de certaines chances
dans l'accès à sa cour est donc bien sûr
peut-être fait-elle partie d'un certain
de tradition pour certaines personnes et
dans certains endroits en tout cas en ce
qui nous concerne effectivement je le
réitère nous sommes pour l'interdiction
de la chasse à courre et pour le fait de
réguler plus précisément la chasse est
de permettre l'utilisation de l'espace
rural pas seulement aux chasseurs tous
les jours mais aussi à d'autres
personnes qui des fois sans perturber
par les chasseurs vous savez très bien
être plus en plus d'accidents de chasse
mais savait très bien que plus en plus
de gens qui en meurt vous savez très
bien que l'utilisation des armes par les
chasseurs n'est pas suffisamment
contrôler et réguler ni même le forme et
donc plus à vous le savez très bien et
donc tout ce que nous proposons en fait
ne va pas alors de la ruralité pari de
vous dire que moi j'habite une petite
commune rurale de 6000 habitants et pas
dans une ville en tout cas la première
des grandes mesures que vous proposez
c'est la création d'un ministère de la
ruralité avec un secrétariat aux
ressources renouvelables incorporant la
chasse la pêche et la forêt guillemets
darroch qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
cette idée d'un grand ministère de la
ruralité
écoutez je pense surtout que en
l'occurrence un certain nombre de
ministères en france aujourd'hui qui
devrait être redécoupés effectivement
est
rendue plus transversaux parce que
autant parle par exemple de des
ressources naturelles il faut comprendre
la ruralité mais qu'on parle aussi
d'autres d'autres secteurs qui
aujourd'hui sont dispersés dans des
données dans des ministères différents
quand on passe de la forêt c'est pareil
aujourd'hui effectivement je sommes
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faudrait un
vrai ministère qui s'occupe
de la forêt et de la filière bois par
exemple pour parler de la ruralité donc
opposé par principe à ce genre de
regroupement ou deux
recentralisation d'un certain nombre de
ministères mais nous avons aussi à
certains de propositions qui touchent à
la police de la ruralité de
l'environnement laissant plus de voix
hier au maire laissant plusieurs maires
ruraux par exemple sur leur territoire
en laissant plus de moyens pour leur
permettre effectivement de réguler leur
espace trouvera dans leur l'essor tout
cela me paraît aller dans le bon sens
au soin de me fallut alors un point
d'accord yves d'amécourt le gouvernement
castex lui s'était dotée en juillet 2020
d'un secrétaire d'état dédié à la
ruralité c'est pas suffisant selon vous
nous ce que l'on souhaite c'est que
parce que vous savez c'est dans le monde
rural que sont toutes les ressources
donc aujourd'hui le ministère de
l'écologie nous implanter des éoliennes
un peu partout il ya des régions rurales
proches de métropole je pense notamment
au médoc où on a interdiction de
construire parce que comme on veut
densifier la métropole et sûrs et a
ajouté deux cent mille habitants on
interdit de construire dans le médoc
pour préserver la nappe qui est sous les
maisons que l'on construirait pour
alimenter en eau la métropole ce n'est
pas notre schéma de développement nous
nous sommes contre la métropolisation
nous sommes contre la densification
nous sommes pour que l'on équipes les
plus communes villes moyennes un petit
peu partout en france que l'on
rééquipent les bourgs centres que l'on
installe des petites entreprises de
première et deuxième transformation dans
les zones rurales pour pouvoir
transformer notamment les produits
agricoles et forestiers aujourd'hui
notre filière forestière elle est
déficitaire de 7 milliards d'euros on
importe 60% des fruits on importe 40%
des légumes on apporte 85% des bouquets
de fleurs qui ont été offerts à la saint
valentin on importe la moitié de la
viande blanche 25 % de la viande rouge
et on continue à émettre des normes de
toutes sortes sur la tête de nos
agriculteurs pour les empêcher de
produire et donc nous nous sommes en
opposition frontale avec tout ce système
avec beaucoup de greenwashing beaucoup
de marketing avec une volonté de casser
notre modèle rural etc europe ecologie
les verts qui aujourd'hui porte ce
schéma mortifère pour nos zones rurales
dit benarroch répondait à ce que vous
venez d'entendre
vous même avez échappé que nous étions
au pouvoir est aux manettes thorzain en
nombre de métropoles sauf depuis alors
et de l'état il me semble que les
politiques conviennent de nommer qui
vient d'être nommé sur plutôt de la
responsabilité de ceux qui exercent
aujourd'hui qui sort dans les exécutifs
pour les exécuter il me semblait
également vous venez de faire une belle
démonstration en faisant le bilan de ce
qu'est aujourd'hui
le monde paysan et l'agriculture en
france vous venez de faire une preuve
que ce qui fonctionne et que vous voulez
le faire perdurer ce que vous l'avez dit
vous-même en introduction tout à l'heure
il faut pas changer de système agricole
etc vous venez de montrer vous même le
résultat de ce système les résultats des
politiques qui se sont suivies agricole
commune européenne vous venez de le
montrer effectivement il faut en sortir
c'est une certitude il faut sortir de ce
type d'exploitation de la nature et de
la ruralité qui amène à la fois l'un des
désastres environnementaux et en même
temps on y amène à aa une capacité
économique de survivre pour la plupart
des zones rurales et de nos agriculteurs
donc il faut effectivement sortir en
proposant des solutions doivent aussi
être adapté à la
à la façon de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et pour la
protection de la biodiversité donc on
peut pas non plus enlever toutes les
normes et tout permettre vous dites on
veut on a implanté des eonias les
écologistes ils ont apporté les
éoliennes nulle part
de notre zone on appelle la capacité de
décider de les implanter ou pas même les
plus fervents partisans de l'énergie
nucléaire de vous fait sûrement partie
et même été
favorables à l'énergie nucléaire
nous explique qu'en fait on va avoir
besoin d'un énorme développement de
l'éolien en france pour pouvoir arriver
au moment où les centrales nucléaires si
on va sur cette voie là seront
construites et qu'opérationnel pour
fournir l'énergie benoît sait très bien
qu'elle ferme espoir
vous savez également très bien par
tourner à 90% est parc éolien qui n'a
aucune incidence et qui n'a aucune
incidence dans le futur ni sur ses au
démantèlement ni avec son exploitation
au nez avec les matériaux qu'ils
utilisent sur la nature et sur
l'environnement actuellement pas le cas
d'autres énergies donc il faut savoir ce
qu'on veut dans un programme qui
conçoit tous et qui prend en compte de
la globalité des problèmes aux panneaux
trouvant confrontés et pas uniquement
d'une partie ou d'une autre pour lequel
on trouverait une solution tout à fait
désincarné par rapport au reste de la
société ou au reste de l'organisation
qui vivent d'amécourt il nous reste
malheureusement que quelques secondes
avant de clore ce débat peut être le mot
le mot de la fin
monsieur le sénateur ferait bien de se
renseigner sur le désastre des éoliennes
sur les problèmes sanitaires que posent
les éoliennes sur les problèmes
environnementaux que posent les
éoliennes depuis la création et
l'extraction des terres rares jusqu'à la
conception et à la construction des
éoliennes il ferait bien de se
préoccuper du coc scandale démocratique
que constitue les éoliennes qui sont
implantées sans tenir compte de l'avis
des populations locales et des maires
locaux et ils feraient bien de se
renseigner du désastre économique que
sont les éoliennes qui en fait ne
produisent pas l'électricité qu'on
attend d'elle en tout cas un grand merci
à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
d'échanger de débattre ce matin sur rtl
france merci à vous d'y benarroch
sénateur europe ecologie les verts des
bouches du rhône merci à vous merci à
vous yves d'amécourt porte parole le
mouvement de la ruralité conseiller
régional elle mais l'air de nouvel axe
thème